we all want to wake up and feel like
what we do matters if you woke up and
you felt every day that you don't matter
to somebody else that the work you do is
meaningless it doesn't matter that's the
path down to anxiety stress depression
suicides where a lot of people a lot of
people wake up and feel like just
today's doesn't matter nobody cares if I
show up or not but on the other hand if
you felt like today's going to matter
today it'll mean something I'm going to
make something I'm going to show up for
somebody it's going to touch maybe not a
million lives but like one person's life
if you're going to show up and you're
going to take your mom to brunch and
it's going to touch her life and so we
all want to feel like the work that we
do matters people will love helping the
most are the people who currently are
who we used to be so when I said your
purpose comes from your pain whatever
you struggled through that made you feel
like The Biggest Loser of all time is
now what you want to help other people
through cuz there's lots of people right
now who feel like that loser and they'll
learn from you in a way that they won't
learn from me or Eddie or Oprah or
somebody else cuz you have a different
story need motivation watch top believe
in hey it's EV car Michael and I make
these videos because I I need them
because I want to wake up every single
day and get pushed by somebody who's
doing a lot more than me and in watching
their videos it inspires me to be bolder
to have more courage and to go chase
down the life of my dreams and I hope it
does the same for you so today let's
learn from me and my team's take on my
top 10 rules for Success
enjoy helping and serving is hardwired
into our brains you know it's the same
they did functional MRIs on people
brains and found the same part of the
brain lights up when you're serving or
helping as when you're having food and
having sex so it's like it we We crave
the desire to want to help people but
there's a difference between just
helping somebody cross the street or
holding the door for somebody or buying
the coffee like these little acts of
kindness
versus when you see somebody who's like
you and you help them overcome something
that then years later like when Eddie
says 5 years ago I don't know when I
talk talk to you haven't picked up the
phone and called me and how much of a
difference it made right that's that's
the stuff that makes me feel I don't
even remember I don't remember talking
to
any I'll show you the email you'll get
AI out of it you I mean I remember you
outside the bathroom so
that but like that those are the kind of
things that feel really good it makes me
want to keep doing it right that Eddie
said hey you took a chance on me and
gave me half an hour of your time or
however long we talked when I was just
getting started I mean do that for a ton
of people who also don't go anywhere
right is it so it's not like it's great
to have a success story but not
everybody turns out to be an Eddie as
well uh but that becomes proof that I
should keep doing it makes me feel good
right you stopping me outside the
bathroom leading to this you know we
have a good conversation it makes me
want to say yes to the next guy if it's
a total you know like a disaster and we
the building's locked and his
microphone's not set up and he's like oh
maybe I don't say yes to the next guy I
don't know right
so but we all want to feel like the work
we do matters isn't important to people
and every time we feel that it does so
much more for our soul than just holding
the door for somebody or doing a random
act of kindness rule number two is stop
comparing yourself to others as a
Creator we often tend to kind of compare
ourselves to other others and and lose
the focus of the people who are already
here who are already following us and
and enjoying the stuff we have showing
love and we try to kind of focus on the
stuff we don't have so so that one
really resonated this is one of the
things that held me back the most
because my biggest fear is disappointing
people my biggest fear is that I'm G to
I'm going to get on stage or I'm going
to come to an interview and I'm going to
let you down and I'm not going to have
an answer and I'm not going to know what
to say and I don't want to waste your
time I don't want to waste the
audience's time and that used to hold me
back a lot from keeping the momentum
going I might start one thing and then
like there's an opportunity and and then
say no or cancel or or back out or like
hope they would cancel on me because my
I would be afraid that I would
disappoint people so the thing that
always saved me that I still use today
is focus on who you are serving you know
like focus on who you are serving
instead of who you aren't we in in the
comparison game of starting a YouTube
channel or starting an Instagram account
or getting on Tik Tok it's always easy
to look at well but look at look at
whoever you know look at the number one
look at what Joe Rogan's doing or look
at what Evan carmichel is doing or look
at what whoever else is doing and the
game of who you're not never ends
there's always somebody who's better
than you at something right like the
only thing that you're best in the world
that is being Teemo right the only thing
I'm best in the world is being EV carak
on there's always people who are better
than me at all these other skill sets
that I want to learn and get better and
that's great because we never want to
stop learning you never want to have it
all figured out we want to be able to
climb forever but if you're only living
in the world of I'm not enough and like
who you're comparing yourself to I think
people that's what will often lead to
burnout that's what lead to people
quitting that's what lead to people
killing their momentum as opposed to
saying I am helping people right like
focus on who you are serving instead of
who you're not so in my first videos my
first video on
YouTube had three comments on it in a
year and one was my mom and one was my
sister and then one was some random guy
you know I was like so in a year of my
first video going up when people are
like I didn't get any comment man my
first video for a year only had one
comment by some random guy who I didn't
know and I saw that and like hey
somebody commented on my video this is
great and so if you can focus on people
you know that they post something
Instagram and they have 40 views on a
video and he said I'm such a failure
only 40 people saw this video well
imagine if you were going to go speak at
a library or or a school event or
something like 40 people showed up
wouldn't you be excited wouldn't you be
nervous wouldn't you be like oh my God
there's 40 people here how going to see
me but because it's it's online we feel
like we're just a failure cuz somebody
else posted one and they got 40,000 and
you're sitting here with 40 and so I
always just focused on who I was serving
those 40 people like 40 people watch
this video and for maybe for one of
those people that this was a
lifechanging video that for one person
the thing that I said was the piece of
advice that they needed to move the
needle forward in their life and that
always gave me
more fulfillment more happiness more
positivity knowing that I am helping
some people and that I can continue to
help more and when you start doing the
work to help and focus on those 40 they
take you to the 40,000 like if you do a
great job nurturing your community then
they take you to their friends and their
friends and their friends and that's how
you build up and grow so yeah I think um
the comparison game can often uh hold us
back fact there's some Advanced
strategies around that that can work but
when you focus on who you are serving
instead of who you're not I think it
leads to a lot more happiness which
leads to a lot more momentum as well
rule number three is serve people was
the serving with the purpose to serve
was also a kind of like something
serving yourself to was that were you
attached to that
serving yeah I mean the ultimate form of
happiness is serving yeah I know if you
want fulfillment it doesn't exist unless
I don't think it exists unless you are
serving other people like I think as
humans we want to wake up and feel like
today is going to matter everybody wants
to wake up and feel like today is going
to matter and mean something to somebody
else and some of us you know you and I
we want to impact the world we want to
have a big you know ripple effect that
that our positivity you know reaches
everybody uh and other people you know
my wife they just want to serve the
closest people in our family you know
like the 25 closest people to us but in
either case we all want to wake up and
feel like today is going to matter and
mean something to somebody else if you
woke up every day and felt like it
didn't matter if you woke up today and
felt like nobody cares if I show up I'm
not doing anything meaningful my boss
doesn't care about me like it's just a
waste of time like that's the path to
depression and anxiety and stress and
suicide and all you know a lot of
problems that we have because people
don't feel like most people wake up and
drive to a job that they hate they don't
feel like what they're doing matters
where on the flip side if you woke up
and felt like today was going to matter
and mean something then you're much more
likely to show up with energy and hope
and optimism and so I'm trying to do
that for me every time I go and help
somebody I feel better right so like
this is part of like we are we are
interconnected as humans we're we want
to feel like we're going to do something
that's going to mean something to
somebody else rule number four is try
different things for people who don't
know what their direction is where they
want to go you said try different things
until you find something that works for
you like can you elaborate on that or
yeah at the beginning it's it's a messy
process because you you grow up in a
circle and it's getting easier with
YouTube and internet Etc but uh if you
grew up I think of me growing up who did
I know it's my parents my family my
school you're kind of restricted by your
environment now at least we have YouTube
videos and you can learn whatever you
want to learn there's people out
there when you're struggling to figure
out what your career should be or what
your next move should be be I think
you'll have moments in life where you
have absolute Clarity you know like
maybe you're in a moment now of absolute
Clarity I want to get my podcast
actually like kicking ass yeah right so
that's where like Blinder on and go kick
ass on your podcast right you don't need
more you don't need to get into nfts and
like some Ai and crazy stuff like go
kickass in your podcast when you have
Clarity and there's other moments in
life and it's not just a per like you
have moments in life where you don't
know what to do next you sell your
podcast it blows up you sell it and
you're done it's like oh wow what do I
do and that's where you expand open to
say okay I need to try a bunch of stuff
to see what connects with me so should
everybody be an entrepreneur no but
should everybody try yeah because how do
you know you know should everybody love
sushi no but should everybody try yeah
because how do you know what your
favorite food is if you only eat pizza
and hot dogs all day also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is be consistent
how you started to create your YouTube
channel because me myself along with
many other YouTubers out there are
people who want to build their YouTube
following H how what do we do how do how
do we start to build and grow our
YouTube channel one is you just start I
think people are in their head too much
I think
people they're trying to be perfect
you're you're some big hos plan up in
your head and then as a result you don't
do anything so you need to start you
need a phone film your phone up turn it
sideways and start the film and post
your first
video what
Marlo first video is going to be
terrible ever in your life like you got
up on a bicycle and you fell off you
know you didn't just get up and ride so
don't expect to get on YouTube and be
great on camera you know you you could
have great like even you you've got
great speaking skills and you're great
with people and you love interviewing
you love talking it's still a learning
process to get great in front of the
camera some people can short shortcut
that path but it's still a path and so
just start get out of your way stop
being perfect expect it to suck and just
start two I would say you need to be
consistent so it doesn't matter where
you start where you start is not going
to be where you finish but you have to
move and you got to move consistently
and so there's a great quote I think it
was Will Smith but was talking about how
I'm not responsible for where I started
you know I was born where I was born I
can't change that but I'm responsible
for where I finish I get to control
where I go in life no matter where I
started and so people blame their start
and then they don't move but it's like
it's on you doesn't matter where you
came from you you can go anywhere uh and
so consistency you got to practice you
got to get better you got to make daily
content if you want to get good at
something if you want to if you want to
be Oprah Winfree level Talent at
something you have to do it daily you
know if you if you are making a video a
week you're just never going to get
world class at that thing just like
anything else if you if you did anything
else once a week you would never become
world class at that thing might get
decently good if you want to be a chef
and you're only practicing cooking once
a week you're never going to be the oer
Winfree of cook of of that right you're
never going to do it so you need to
practice more so one just start start
with what you have start immediately
today like happy New Year let's start
right now today we're going we're not
waiting and then every day you need to
practice you need to practice practice
and you will slowly get better rule
number six is get excited about learning
how do you feel
about this kind of like world that is
going speeding so quickly with
information how do you find that Focus
to be like okay I have my faith but it's
overwhelming like what how do you find
that kind of
place so first step like the first step
for me is flipping it to get excited so
when something new comes out it's like
okay I'm excited to I'm excited to go
learn that thing AI comes out cool let's
go let's go learn about AI it's like
expecting to suck at it I don't know
anything about AI I don't know how to
program AI I didn't know how to do
anything inside of AI and okay let's go
learn we're we're filming this video on
the on the the day after Instagram or
Facebook just launches threads right
right so threads just come out it's a
Twitter competition and most people are
like oh my gosh threads another social
media thing why do we need another place
to go and doom scroll on and great like
I'm a let me learn about threads this is
exciting I just try to teach myself that
when there's something new let's go
learn it it's exciting because the rate
of change is not going to go slower
right I agree so so this becomes your
key uh
adaptation technique is that anytime
something new comes out get excited go
learn about it this is how you can start
to win and for anybody who is earlier on
in their
Journey whenever something new comes out
that actually becomes your secret hack
to go off and win so if you're trying to
get started and you're on Twitter it
might be hard for you to to win right
now because people have already been it
doesn't mean that you can so you start
you start creating great but go to
threads it's brand new it's all the
people who are on Twitter like don't
want to go to threads because they built
up Their audience all the people in
Hollywood didn't want to go to
YouTube right like where's Brad Pitt's
YouTube channel he should be crushing
right
now because he doesn't want to start
over right this is the problems like
people don't want to start over and I
don't know anything about Brad Pit no
shade at Brad uh but like some people
make the jump like Will Smith make the
jump and like starts blowing up on
YouTube but a lot of people don't a lot
of people stick to one platform and then
they they slowly become irrelevant m so
when something new comes up this is your
chance to go off and win like you might
not beat Joe Rogan at podcasting but you
can beat him on threads or you can get
close to him on threads and a lot of the
people who are are winning in that first
platform just don't want to go and start
over on the second one and so this is
your chance to get ahead and so whether
it's AI whether it's threads whether
it's an update to the YouTube algorithm
whether it's whatever the thing is
there's more
coming and there and there's more coming
too so training yourself to be the
person who gets excited for new changes
because that's your chance to go and win
have a bigger impact make more money
like whatever actually drives you spread
more faith right whatever actually is
driving you this is your opportunity to
go off and do it and so for me that's
always been the default where like okay
why I don't it's always been a default I
think I've trained myself um to get more
excited about the new things that are
coming up uh and I just go in with a
student mind expect to suck you know
like I don't somebody asked me about
threads today like hey what's your
thread strategy like I don't know I'm
two days in like I'm trying to figure it
I don't even know what this is yet I'm
I'm maybe not the smartest person but
I'm I'm trying to understand it as we go
or when some new AI tool drops okay
let's understand what the heck this
thing even does and learning how to use
it so but it's just getting excited
about it and putting in a little bit of
effort to learn how to do it because so
many people they just get stuck on I
don't know how
and it's new and scary and so I don't do
anything where really you're actually
not that far away from making momentum
if you just put in a little bit of
effort rule number seven is follow the
feeling are you of the opinion then that
if somebody has a job but they have a
feeling that they want to be um an
entrepreneur but they're afraid of
leaving their job are you of the opinion
that they should uh take a take steps
towards that and and if you have a
feeling for something try it and just
see and expect to suck but at least you
tried and you can see you know do you
want to go off and do it again you had a
feeling in in the coffee shop to come
and ask me to connect if you didn't
follow the feeling that would have been
it like I would have my my breakfast
with Joe and then cow and off right and
I may never see you again you had the
feeling you followed it and it may not
always be good like maybe I'm in maybe
I'm an ass maybe you're like dude get
out of my face you're weird stalking me
out of the bathroom right like maybe
like you
you don't know what would happen but you
have a feeling and you have to follow
the feeling cuz otherwise you teach
yourself that the things that come to
you are not great because if every time
you get an idea and you don't follow
through you're teaching yourself that
your ideas suck versus I have an idea
I'm going to give it a shot that's a
great identity to start to build it
doesn't mean go mortgage your home to go
start a podcast Studio like expect to
suck and find the smallest possible
thing to just go and get started so
somebody who's working a corporate job
that hates their life okay you're you're
never going to win doing work that you
hate so so longer term something has to
change it doesn't mean go like take a
flamethrower to your boss's office or
something now like you need the money
you need the cool awesome but longer
term like we have to make a change
somewhere because you will never be
great doing work that you hate you're
never going to make the money you're
never going to be happy if you're doing
work you hate every day so how you going
to get out of that hole that you're in
is it going to be somebody else telling
you what you should do with your life
that's going to be like you have ideas
for what you it'd be cool if I could do
this okay go give it a shot try it see
if you liked it your first podcast
sucked cool and you get better like
you're better at eight episodes in than
I was at like 300 episodes in right so
but you try and so I think if you have
the feeling you want to teach yourself
that you come up with great ideas and
and they're worth at least giving a shot
to instead of just saying you know this
sushi on the table I don't like sushi
without even giving a shot cuz it sounds
gross like if you had to explain what
Sushi is raw fish with with fish eggs
and seaweed with rice and super spicy
mustard that doesn't sound appetizing
right like why would anybody eat that
but then you eat it I like with you guys
but but you don't know until you try it
so like you're judging things before
you're trying it and especially when
it's yourself you're judging your ideas
before you even try it you're building
uh the belief that your ideas suck and
that you suck and then you stay stuck
and so I I at least you know encourage
myself to try to flip that that I have
ideas that saying yes to you okay let's
go I'm not going to judge it let's go do
it rule number eight is shift your
mindset what skills does someone need to
get into this area of wanting to be an
entrepreneur what does it take I don't
think skills are the problem I think I
think you can learn anything if you have
a a commitment and passion to learn um
learn is your one word you know I think
I think learn the desire and willingness
to to go through crap and learn and get
better you could you could pick up
anything and I think I'm the Testament
to that in that I suck at the start of
my channel if you go back it's
embarrassing watching my first content
it's really really bad but I just kept
learning and said I can get better I'm
gon to improve I'm GNA keep working I'm
going to keep getting better and and it
worked and so more than any specific
skill
I think it's the mindset it's it's the
desire to learn and understand that I
can do better if you take that into any
field uh and match you with some
self-awareness I think you're set like
there's so many different ways to win as
an entrepreneur there's so many
different ways yes you may not win the
same way that Gary ve win and so to have
the self-awareness to know hey I'm I'm
Mara I'm great at talking to people I'm
going to do a talk show and then you can
model success and you can learn learn
from Oprah and you can learn from Larry
King and you can learn from all the
great talk show hosts and model some of
their Styles and every time you do that
you learn a little bit more to be a
better Mara and keep growing and keep
getting better number nine is cut out
negativity what do you think would
gravitate towards negativity a lot more
when we know it doesn't make us feel
good because it definitely drains you it
causes an impact I think it's biological
it's like it's like from the history of
US struggling right has to be you I mean
I don't know I don't not I'm not a
scientist and I don't have all the
answers there for sure but but like why
do we slow down and look at a car
accident even if it's on the other side
of the road totally get hit by looking
at like if a fight breaks out on the
street is like you're you know you want
to see what happens like where we I
don't know where it comes from but like
it it it definitely is that people would
rather um consume negative things like
if I my first video
was the top 10 rules for Kanye West and
was positive things you can learn from
Kanye if that was a negative like top 10
stupidest things Kan has said it would
it would do so much better because I
think I think if I'm looking at it from
the perspective of what I do is like we
we would rather see people fail than
than try to build ourselves up right you
know it's like oh look at D she she's
got her podcast and she's been on movies
and look at her building her life and
she she made it out and now she's LA and
she's such a big deal and yada y yada
and it's easier for me to try to tear
you down and want to see you fail then
for me to say huh like maybe I can fix
my life maybe I can go to La too maybe I
can start a podcast maybe I can and and
whatever the things are that you know
jealousy is really just um ins
inspiration that's been
mutated oh wow if I if I'm jealous of
you I'm actually inspired by you but I
don't know how to handle it so I take
take it
negative
totally so it's easier for me to tear
you
down than for me to try to work on
myself because I don't have to do any
work that way right it's like yeah but
then yeah but she like totally sold her
soul to go do that and she and I'll make
I make up some stuff that like doesn't
even make sense but it allows me to stay
where I'm at where I am right so that's
why a lot of a lot of and our friends
and family will often say not to go do
something because if you go off if you
go off to LA and you start becoming a
movie star and you start meeting people
what does it mean for
me you know like you left me behind and
and now my life sucks because you're
showing what's possible and I'm living
in a fake reality I don't want to accept
that so it's not possible you must have
had to do something super
scammy terrible yeah like you killed
somebody or whatever you know
you hide someone in the closet and it's
not coming out yeah so I think that's
like it we don't doing work on yourself
is hard very learning new skills and
making new connections and going to a
new country or new city is hard it's
really hard and we don't want to do hard
things but your great life is on the
other side of of hard things and so when
we see somebody else who looks like us
come from similar
background we want to find a reason why
that person should not be successful
we'd rather hate on them than Be
Inspired not everybody but a lot of
people yeah because we want we prefer to
say stuck than the grow and Rule Number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus Clips is stop planning start doing
the idea with 2% difference is when we
come up with an idea like I'm going to
launch a YouTube channel I'm going to
write my own book I want to start a
Instagram book account like I want to do
whatever we all have these ideas of what
we want to do the first thing that we
typically do is start planning
researching planning who's done it
before who can I model and learn from
all these ideas and we create this giant
list of plans and what we're trying to
do is plan to the 100% which is like
that's what our final destination is
going to look like how do I plan to get
my goal and then we end up waking up the
next day and you look at your plan
you're like I can't do that I thought
what I'm not that there's no way I can
do that it's not even like us telling
our friends or our spouses or it's it's
us telling ourselves that we can't do
this and so the problem is we used our
energy our our our mojo our our best
like high Vibes on planning instead of
on doing where again the biggest thing
people are missing just momentum
planning doesn't really count as
momentum you have to go and do something
and so instead of worrying about
planning to get to 100% of our goal
completed the 2% difference is just
start with the first 2% what's what's
the first 2% and we don't care about
getting to the end goal we just care
about getting started so that was me in
writing the book okay well I'm going to
write the book after this Instagram live
I'm going to start right now it's easy
for all the thoughts to start to
overwhelm yourself and I did like I
don't have time for this I this is not
on my plan I'm busy I have to I feel
like I'm going to be a bad father a bad
husband a bad uh manager a bad CEO like
I don't have time for this right and I
share all those thoughts in the book too
so you can kind of peek behind the
window it wasn't like I really was
desperately wanting to do this going in
and then uh I just started writing so
like if anybody out here you want to
write your first book cool the the 2%
difference is write the first page and
it's okay if it sucks if you want to
start a YouTube channel the 2%
difference is record your first video
and it's going to suck awesome cool but
more important than planning how to make
a book or planning how to record a
YouTube video is to just start doing the
thing and you build momentum if you want
to start building a healthy you want to
you want to you want to start working
out right this is where we often get
overwhelmed like I want to out I want to
look good next year I want to I want to
feel comfortable naked or whatever we
want to be able to do cool so it starts
off with this very simple concept but
then the doing becomes really
complicated because as you start to plan
and research a health Journey right it's
like oh well do I do weights do I do
cardio how much of each do I do uh do I
do classes do I hire a coach do I how
much am I supposed to wait am I going to
hurt myself am I going to injure my back
trying to do this thing maybe I should
take maybe I should go do soccer or pick
up a sport or pick up uh basketball or
oh but do I need a partner to run with
like can I overtrain and how about
nutrition like do I need to drink am I
drinking too much water not enough water
do I need to go carnivore or vegan and
all of a sudden it's like so many this
is what happens we get so overwhelmed
with all the potential options which
then leads us to try to plan plan plan
plan plan plan plan some more but then
you can't understand all of the various
options and then we end up getting this
is C I'm not doing I'm I'm out I'm done
and then you stop before you even
started right and so the key is 2%
difference if you want to start a health
Journey get down on the floor and do
five push-ups or 10 or two right is it
going to make you extra strong no but
it's the first step and most people wait
a decade to take the first step and so
that's what the 2% difference is all
about do you have any tips for creators
that are starting out on the platform
and are looking to build their audience
organically oh yeah yeah no no I'm I'm
answering the question okay the thing
is you need to open your heart to
people ah so I asked you a heart
question MH and you shut it down and
move back to head it yeah right cuz you
said I'm on I want to document my self-
Lov Journey that's why I'm doing my
house and my workout you said I want to
document my self- Lov Journey so I ask
you well where you struggle with self
love that's that's a heart opening
opportunity and then you went to well
I've I've grow I've I've fixed a lot and
I'm I'm much more and I don't really
struggle with that anymore okay cool and
maybe you don't awesome but where do you
struggle because if you're telling the
stories about 17-hour days and photo
shoots and it's like the Glam life cool
but it's not really
relatable so what are you struggling
with what's the negative voice in your
mind cuz you're you're you're you're
going to you're part Fierce badass going
to show up and cry rush and want to
change the world right that's in you and
then you're also insecure and self-doubt
and like is this even worth it and when
is it going to happen for me and like
all of those emotions too and all of us
are yeah but that's the heart stuff that
if you can figure out how to dive into
that stuff on a video people will then
start to love you and feel connected to
you and you're still badass Fierce
chasing down your goals so showing oh if
you're writing songs with your head and
not your heart it's not going to
win yeah if you're going into a studio
think okay what is a hit song going to
be and let me just copy whoever and this
is the track versus no I have something
to say this is what's on my heart like
those will be the better songs
vulnerability yeah and so if you're
already doing that in your art now it's
bringing that to just a new form of art
okay and what you want is people to
actually join you the language you use
is great I'm on my journey of self love
and if you want to swap that out for
something else cool but you take people
on the journey then they want to join
with you on the journey but you have to
let them in not just kind of watching
from the outside I'm going to teach you
the entrepreneur success formula this is
the formula it's very simple it's easy
to apply that when you actually execute
it it will change the course of your
life and your business the entrepreneur
success formula are you ready you need
to if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur combine
what you love doing with what brings
value to other
people people mess us up what you love
doing with what brings value to other
people in that intersection is your next
great genius amazing business idea
here's what most people do most people
just pick one most people either pick
what they love
doing but they can't figure out how to
bring value to other people so you've
got a hobby if you love doing something
it's just fills you up it's amazing but
it never brings value to other people
then you never get paid you've got a
really fulfilling Hobby and that could
be great and your hobby can be something
you do in the evenings and weekends and
it fills up your soul but you'll never
turn that into a business if you don't
figure out how to bring value to other
people so you're stuck always having to
have a job or go work for somebody else
while you're doing your hobby on the on
the weekends evenings on the side Etc so
those are the people who just Chase what
they love doing right they chase Your
Passion amazing there's other people
people a lot of entrepreneurs who just
go after the money just try to bring
value just go after opportunity right
that's the only focus like I'll do
whatever it takes I need to be a
millionaire by the time I'm X years old
I'll do whatever it takes but you won't
you will not do whatever it takes
because as soon as it gets hard you're
going to lose and the problem is you're
going up against people who love it pick
whatever industry you open up a magazine
or or website it shows you the hottest
businesses for next year these are the
industries that will take off and you
have to get into it it's like oh wow
that's hot I'm going to go off and do
those things if you don't absolutely
love it right this part here if you
don't actually love it what you love
doing what it brings value to other
people if you don't absolutely love it
you're going to lose because you're
going up against people who do love it
if it's just a strategy for you but for
other people they love it you're going
to lose every time you're going to lose
every time because while you're counting
the hours and while you're you're trying
to figure oh my gosh when is this going
to pay off you're going up against
people who aren't even tracking it who
get lost in it who 12 hours later
they're still doing the thing because
they love it so much and they can't
believe that like where is the time gone
so it has to be in that combination so
many entrepreneurs start a business
because they think they're going to make
a lot of money and they end up going
broke and it wasn't because the idea was
bad the idea could have been fantastic
the problem was you didn't love it
enough you didn't care about it enough
it was just a strategy it was just an
opportunity for you instead of being not
something that you love so the
entrepreneur success
formula you start with doing what you
love and then you figure out how to
bring value to other people doing it
people don't know what balance is for
them I meet so many entrepreneurs who
want to be like Kevin o or Mark Cuban or
Elon Musk and built these giant
businesses but they're not willing to do
the sacrifices that go along with it if
you look at their personal lives you
probably don't want to be like them I
look at Steve jobs who's on my wall at
home and I want to be a Visionary like
him but I don't want to be a father like
him right I don't want to put in that
amount of work and then not be present
for my family the key is figuring out
what balance looks like for you what a
successful life looks like for you and
that may mean that you don't go un build
a billion dollar company what does life
look like for you we're constantly
judging ourselves based off of other
people's schedules based off of other
people's results and saying I can't do
everything thing I want to be like this
and like that and like this and like
that and like this and like that and
having no clear picture for what an what
a complete picture looks like for you
that's the problem you can't look like
the Rock and build a billion dollar
business and be the greatest father in
the world and right like you have to
pick you have to understand what balance
looks like for you and not judge
yourself against other people's version
of balance
period what I like doing doing
personally is what I call trying on hats
so I will look at what other people are
doing and use it as source of
inspiration as opposed to judgment
against myself how poor I'm doing right
what most people will do is you'll look
at somebody like Kevin o and say man
look at what he's doing I I suck I can't
do that I'm not working hard enough I
look at that as inspiration as I had to
try on to say maybe I can do this and I
and I then I try it but my goal isn't to
be the next Kevin o ly my goal is to be
the best seven Carmichael right my goal
isn't to be the next rock or Steve Jobs
or anybody else is to be the best seven
carmichel and you get that by trying on
other people's hats it's not going to
quite fit their schedule won't quite fit
working out for 4 hours a day like the
rock does that may not fit and it
doesn't you look at me that's why I
don't look like the rock cuz I'm not
working out 4 hours a day you have to
try on their hat see how it fits see how
you like it make the tweaks and
adjustment to get the perfect thing for
you and then when you when you found
your version of
balance you're less likely to be pulled
in a million different directions for
what other people expect of you and for
what other people out there are doing
and you feel crappy about yourself cuz
you're not doing enough so here's a
quick example right now I'm filming this
uh at the beginning of January and my
son has an extra week of Christmas break
everybody else is back to work and I am
doing a hybrid right now so most kids
get two weeks off he's got three weeks
off I am spending half my day with
him having fun doing doing father son
things and half my day working so the
morning I'm here right now filming
videos for you Nina is in Costco can we
see the Costco sign there see Nina's in
Costco there's
Costco I'm filming I'm s in the morning
making YouTube videos for you guys and
in the afternoon I'm going to be with
with my son I want to do that I'm okay
with that I'm missing opportunities
right now I could be making content all
day long those videos maybe the video
that I would have made this afternoon is
one that gets 10 million Vues Vues views
and blows up my channel right like maybe
that happens I'm okay with that I'm okay
with spending time with my son I want do
that I'm not following through with
people that I should I can leave that
until next week I'm not making content
on my Instagram like I normally would uh
because I want to spend time with my son
and that's my version of balance and and
I'm okay with that and you can judge me
and say that's a wrong decision or you
can judge me and say that's a great
decision either way I don't care because
I'm living my version of balance I'm
proud of myself for my actions and
that's all that matters are you proud of
yourself for how you are living your
life period when you go home and you
look at yourself in the mirror are you
proud of today are you proud of what you
did are you proud of how you spent your
time your version of balance may not be
perfect not yet and listen mine isn't
either I'm constantly tweaking
constantly hacking constantly learning
constantly adjusting because even if you
found your perfect version of balance
it's going to adjust right it's going to
adjust next year won't be the same 5
years definitely won't be the same and
so it's those little micro tweaks and
adjustments but the most important thing
is understanding what are your goals
what are your Ambitions not just
business we tend to F entrepreneur we
tend to focus just on our business
here's my goals for this year here's my
goals for where I want to be in the next
5 years right you set your
goals but you don't have the same
structure for your family you don't have
the same structure for your for your
life look at your
schedule look in your schedule how many
of the things in your schedule are
business things
have you scheduled your family time do
you treat dad as important as you would
a business meeting so I schedule in my
time with my wife I protect it if
something is going to go against it for
example Saturdays I spend with
Nina uh I haven't done every single
Saturday some opportunities have come up
but if I'm going to move something on a
Saturday I have to talk to n about it
and it's got to be an important
opportunity otherwise left to my own
devices I would just work all the time
right I love it I love my work I'm
obsessed with my work I love making
videos for you guys I love responding to
the comments like I love I love I love I
love what I do if Nina's out on a Friday
night with her friends 85% chance I'm
just going to be working cuz it's not
work cuz it's it's love it's enjoyment
it's fulfillment it's service it it's
all the great stuff for me but then when
I step above it that's my addiction
right like entrepreneurship helping you
guys is my addiction when I step above
it doing that 24/7 actually doesn't lead
to me having the life that I want cuz I
want to be a good father and I want to
be a good husband and I want to take
care of myself physically so those other
things you have to schedule into your
calendar don't just schedule in the
business things you schedule in your
life so that when you step above this is
a great exercise for the next week
create your life schedule for the next
week that when you step above when you
say okay yes I'm going to wake up and
I'm GNA I'm going to work out or I'm
going to watch those videos or I'm going
to spend this time with my wife or
husband or boyfriend girlfriend or
children or parents right whatever you
need for your life if you need to call
your mom every day schedule that in if
you need to hang out with your family
every weekend schedule that in right
whatever is super important to you if
you have to watch the game every Sunday
schedule that in put it on your calendar
that leads to a happy life for you what
is your version of balance that's all
that matters your version of of balance
to create the best you that when you
step above when you look at your
calendar and say if I did these things I
would be a happy successful fulfilled
person period And when you've done that
when you've created that then have the
courage to step into it and live it
regardless of what the people around you
are judging you for cuz you're always
going to get
judgment some people say you're doing
way too much and some people say you're
not doing enough you're building your
business some people will say you're
working way too hard and other people
would say you're barely you're barely
starting keep going like you call this
work right somebody's always going to
have an opinion on what you should be
doing with your life and until you
determine you figure out you understand
what balance looks like for you to get a
happy successful fulfilled life on your
own terms write it down and then create
your calendar and then stick to your
calendar and have other people are
judging you for it you thank them for
their opinion but you let it bounce off
you cuz you're happy and they're not
your next big step forward in life will
come from a big shift in perspective on
one of your beliefs your habits your
routines the results that you're getting
all come from what you believe to be
true about your life and the world and
for you to get different results than
you're getting right now in your life
you're going to have to change your
perspective on one or more of your
beliefs so this topics makes me think
about my favorite comment of all time if
you think about my YouTube channel I've
had it for 11 years and I don't know how
many thousand of thousands of comments
my favorite comment of all time was we
profiled a black entrepreneur and one of
the guys in a comment said growing up my
parents taught me that black people were
the n-word and you just changed my
perspective today I was willing to learn
from a black man and it blew my mind
because when I first set out to make my
channel uh it wasn't really about race
or willingness to learn from other
people people it was it was more hey
these people have accomplished success
you should go and learn from them I
wasn't set out to try to solve sexism or
racism or anything uh so big like that
but what had happened was I had enough
credibility with this person and I
didn't know them from anything they just
watched enough of my videos that then
when I made this video on a black man he
decided you know what I'm going to give
it a few minutes and that experience
changed his perspective that then will
hopefully go off and change his life
imagine having that belief that then
changes
what kind of ripple effect that has on
the rest of your life and that's what
happens when you get exposed to New
Opportunities and new people and New
Perspectives you you were raised with a
perspective your parents your family
community a super isolated perspective
that you feel is right and many of those
things may still be right for who you
want to become but if you want to have
greater success greater levels of
confidence greater levels of happiness
and purpose and fulfillment than the
people around you you're going to have
to to believe something that's different
than what they believe you're going to
have to surround yourself with other
people who've actually gone off and done
that thing because the people around you
aren't giving you the thing that you
need and so that's one of my main goals
with this channel I know people come in
to learn from people who are like them
you learn from people who who look like
you who might be the same sex or same
gender in the same industry or use the
same language as you but what I'm really
hoping to do as well is in that process
you came for this one person you came
for this one thought or one idea and I
want to expose you to a whole bunch of
different perspectives all still within
the lens of belief right everything on
my channels all of the channels are
always positive it's always belev it's
always optimistic it's always uplifting
but I want to try to hit you with
different perspectives and angles cuz
Eric Thomas and Joo willink are going to
yell at you through something and Oprah
Winfrey and Wayne Dyer are going to hug
you through something and sometimes
maybe you need to yell and sometimes you
need to hug but I want to give you
different perspectives to help you
become the best friend version of you
okay so how do we make the perspective
shifts that we need to make in our life
to get to the spot that we want to be
I've got a three-step process let's go
step number one is learn to learn from
people that you hate this is one of the
most important things that I can that I
can articulate that I can push you
towards find somebody who's had success
ideally in some kind of related field
but still had some success that you hate
for some reason and force yourself to
learn from them force yourself to find
one thing about them that you can learn
to make you better at what to do so even
looking at my wall here right I like to
tell the story I've got I've got Steve
Jobs here and I got my dad here I want
to be a Visionary like Steve Jobs and a
father like my father I don't want to be
a father like Steve Jobs and a Visionary
like my dad right the whole point of
this is for you to be the best you and
for that to happen you pull different
things from different people you may
Hate Everything About Steve Jobs or
everything about Kanye West at the back
wall there but there's but there's one
thing there's one thing that you can
learn from that person to help you be
better that's often a thing that unlocks
a huge chunk of learning people
typically lock themselves in a box
you've trapped yourself in a box of
learning of saying I'm only going to
learn from these kinds of people and so
you get the same kind of messages over
and over and over again but really if
you want to unlock your learning finding
people who you disagree with who you may
hate you may hate a lot about them but
examining how they've had success a good
starting point is the top 10 on my other
channel right it's always POS if it's
something that I've learned from if I
can learn from them you could probably
learn from them as well there's one
little nugget out of those 10 rules
maybe that can apply to your life and
when I was learning from Kanye West
Kanye West was somebody who used to
bother me a lot I saw somebody who's got
a giant ego somebody who who I I didn't
want to be like but I realized you know
what I can learn from this guy I can
learn from this guy I can learn to think
bigger like Kanye I can learn to be a
better friend if you know the story of
him and John Legend I can learn to be a
better friend like Kanye that you can't
really see that picture there but he's
on a radio interview and and he's saying
In that clip uh the time is now to be
the greatest you I don't want to sit
inside a corporation for the next 30
Years like this is the time the time is
now let's go I believe that I need to
remember that even more like the time is
now not tomorrow not in 3 years not next
month like it's right now the time is
now for you you can learn that from
Kanye right now even if you hate him so
step number one is find somebody who you
hate go to my top 10 Channel or my main
Channel and go back in the archives and
find somebody who you see their picture
and it drives you nuts already great
force yourself to go learn one thing
from that person that's the starting
point for shifting your perspective step
number two is say it's the best it's the
best this is one of the most valuable
perspective shifts that I think any
human can make is when you're faced with
something that's negative something that
that most people will complain of and
the old you used to complain about you
shift it and say this is the best this
is the best this thing that's happening
to me right now this the best this
Corona virus is happening right now for
me it's the best shift your perspective
to say this is the best because what it
does is it moves you from a place of
being complaining and upset and angry
and unproductive into a place of
possibility of resourcefulness of you
now showing to yourself and to the world
what you're capable of and so when I
broke my neck when when there's a fire
alarm going off when we have Corona this
is this is how I stay productive this is
how I stay focused this is how I stay
pushing forward when most people are
complaining and negative is I tell
myself this is the best this is my
chance this is an opportunity and I
think this is this is the one of the
biggest things that entrepreneurs who've
had the biggest success Crush at so many
entrepreneurs have built their
businesses the ones that you look up to
and respect and and admire and want to
be like they built their businesses in
the toughest times they build their
businesses in recessions and depressions
why because they said it's the best so
whatever that thing is that feels
overwhelming all all-encompassing
negative in your life stop complaining
about it and say this is the best I'm
growing I'm getting stronger through
this adversity I'm going to make
something amazing as a result of it and
step number three is the first time yes
rule the first time yes rule is the
first time you get invited to something
or an idea comes to your head say yes
most people are in the no business most
people are looking at all the reasons
why it's not going to work and you can't
do this and you have no skills or
abilities or time or resources you're
always finding out we're in the no
business of why we can't do stuff we've
told ourselves we can't do these things
just say yes the first time this is one
of the things I love most about my wife
nah is I'll come up with all sorts of
crazy ideas and the first time she'll
say yes we'll see right you want to
drive to to Boston with with two
videographers in the back and film The
yes perfect you want to go to sadguru in
Philadelphia and spend 2 days meditate
yes perfect you even though you hate the
cold you want to sit in an ice bath with
whm Hoff when he comes to Toronto and
film behind yes perfect doesn't mean
she's going to do it again she hasn't
sat in a nice bath since but it's a
first time yes the first time yes rule
is one of the biggest mentality shifts
that if you can make you'll open
yourself up to so many more
opportunities I look at dancing for
example trono dance salsa right the
other another business that I run and
operate the number of people who come in
and are scared and super nervous and
it's their first time dancing ever at as
an adult and then you see the shift that
they make in the identity of like I just
did that I danced I never thought I
could dance and here I got a few basic
steps of a move and if they keep coming
back they'll keep getting better A lot
of times you're not making the
perspective shift that you need because
you're not trying enough new stuff cuz
you're into no business first time yes
rule you get an idea somebody asks you
for something somebody wants to try
something with you yes first time yes
doesn't mean you keep doing it and as
long as it doesn't go against your
ethics or your values don't go rob a
bank cuz they said first time yes okay
we're not talking about that kind of
stuff but when you feel a little bit
outside your comfort zone it's like I'm
not the kind of person who does that
first time yes rule just see you might
surprise yourself where are you stuck
right now is it your business is it your
relationships is it your career is it
where is it your mindset your health
habits like where do you feel is the
number one place that you're stuck right
now in your life where are you stuck get
really clear on that because having that
honest conversation with yourself really
matters that's how you can start to make
the change and the point of this is not
to say that you suck and look at the the
disaster you made for yourself and I
can't believe you're not doing better
this is not a negative self- toop
exercise this is a we're going to have
an honest evaluation of where we are
right now this is you sitting down with
you you can look in the mirror you can
Journal you can go for a walk whatever
you need to do to have that conversation
with yourself but figure out what is the
number one area that you feel stuck
right now that you don't want to be
stuck in anymore that if you're still
still stuck in the same spot that you
are in right now one year from today
you're going to be upset you're going to
be upset that you missed an opportunity
that you've wasted another year of your
life so where is that number one area
that you feel stuck right now get some
clarity on it maybe it comes right away
maybe you got to digest it but get some
clarity on that cuz that that's the
starting point to making some changes
your story is your competitive Advantage
why you do what you do where you came
from your history all of the the baggage
the imperfections the vulner all of that
your story is the thing that's going to
help you win as an entrepreneur this is
one of the biggest misconceptions and
one of the hardest things for us to do
as entrepreneurs to put ourselves out
there and share the story we want to be
perfect we see these big Brands we see
people popping off on Instagram and
their perfect life and their perfect
planes and their perfect marketing and
we feel not good enough and we feel like
we have to be like them but people can
smell through it than think about it
you're going up against some big company
right whatever industry you're in
there's some big players more
established than you bigger budgets than
you deeper Pockets than you they've been
there forever they've got the brand name
the history the reputation people know
who they are and you're going up against
them why would somebody buy from you
instead of
them because of your story because
you're going to make me feel special
because in you I see myself I see
somebody who cares I see somebody who's
going to go off and make a difference
where I have no connection to big
company to Big Corporation but what most
entrepreneurs do is they try to look the
part of being the big corporate they
have a really formal website they have a
really
formal Photography they have a really
formal
bio at best you're going to be a junior
junior junior junior version of that big
company I need to know why you do what
you do this is how you win your heart is
your competitive
Advantage why do you care so much and if
you believe like I believe that your
purpose comes from your pain that
whatever you're doing right now your
deep purpose is to help other people who
currently are who you used to be then I
need to know what pain you've come
through because you might have the
answers you might have the solution your
product your service your coaching your
content whatever could actually be the
solution but until I know that you've
come through the thing that I'm
struggling with I'm not going to listen
to you because I'm going to think yeah
right this person doesn't get it this
person doesn't understand me this person
doesn't care meanwhile you do care
meanwhile it's the most important thing
meanwhile you care way more than anybody
else cares but until you actually share
your story nobody's going to
listen this is one of the hardest things
for me to overcome when I started my
business because I always felt well
nobody cares about my story like who
cares it's not about me I I have no need
to be in front of a camera I'm I'm
introverted and shy by Nature I know you
may not believe that in watching these
videos but I am and like I remember
fighting with my agent Steve many times
I Steve nobody cares about what I've
done and my story and I don't I don't
like the spotlight on me so why does it
matter and after years of fighting and
hopefully what took me forever to figure
out if you guys get this in this video
you'll be way further ahead than I was
when I was getting
started people learn through your story
and if you've got a message
you telling your story actually
perpetuates the message so you telling
your story is not about you and your ego
and how you look and how people see you
and prizes and awards and anything it's
about making an impact because when I
know that you've been through what I'm
going through or I know how much you
care about something I'm much more
likely to want to hire you so let me
give you a couple examples I remember uh
I was doing a radio show and when I
first got started uh in in coaching it
was through a live radio show that I was
doing once a week I remember one person
calling in and he had a uh landscaping
business and I asked okay well what's so
different about your landscaping company
cuz he was frustrated that all of these
teenagers and high school kids were
eating up his business where say hey
we'll landscape your yard and we'll do
it for minimum wage and here he is
trying to make more than minimum wage
and he's worried that he has to compete
on price and he can't do it against
these teenagers and so I said well why
do you why do you care so much about
Landscaping man like why did you pick
this business and I hope for all of you
please that you have a story right if
you're picking a business just to make
money you've lost already You've Lost
That that the entrepreneur success
formula is you got to combine what you
love doing with what brings value to
other people you have to love it you
have to have a story if there's no Story
You've Lost go pick something else that
you actually can't connect to but I ask
why did you start this business what
does it mean to you and he
said my mom was my hero and when I was
young she always took me out to the yard
and we did landscaping
together and it's always a connection to
her and then there was a line that he
said that really caught me where he said
every lawn that I go to every customer's
lawn that I go help I treat it like it's
my mom's
lawn and right there I like oh my gosh
this guy cares so much like do you think
the average high school after school
summer job do you think they care as
much about your yard as this guy does
right if he's treating it like it's his
mom's
garden and by sharing that story now
you'd be willing to pay more I'd be
willing to pay him way more than than a
high school kid because I think that
he's going to give a way better service
provide way more value because I
understand the story you can choose at
any moment positivity you can choose at
any moment gratitude you can choose at
any moment service you can choose to
change your mindset in in an instant if
you wanted to the challenge is we're so
living in our subconscious mode that we
don't we don't catch it soon enough we
don't take the action that we're proud
of and then we regret it you know we
regret it later on this morning I woke
up really early I'm very tired I woke up
at 3:45 a.m. for some reason don't know
why uh look at my look at my watch like
3:4 5:00 a.m. what oh man okay tried to
go back to sleep toss turn for about an
hour and then I got up like okay you
know what 4:45 it's almost 5 you know
let's let's get up and I got to work and
started doing things and then the the
crash hit me the crash hit me just not
enough
sleep and everything inside me wanted to
shut down you know I wanted to just take
a complete break not do my walk in the
morning
not not take the dogs out well the dogs
have to go out but not do my routine not
do any my usual stuff not record videos
today's a Tuesday when I record it's
video recording day and it's in these
moments those trying times that you have
to decide who you want to be you have to
decide if you want to choose to be
positive choose to live in gratitude
choose to live in productivity choose to
live in service or not what would the
future you think of your actions right
now and I think 95% of the time the
answer is to push a little harder move
the brake line forward right where where
you would normally take a break move
that forward just a little bit move The
Brak line forward a touch and 5% of the
time you have to be more gent on
yourself when my family dog passed away
when I broke my neck when you know all
sorts of things have happened to me just
like they've happened to you sometimes
the answer is to give yourself a little
more grace to recognize how far you've
come everything that you've done with
the limited amount of resources and time
that you
have but I think if we default to that
then we default to staying stuck and
staying small because life is going to
throw so many different challenges at
you so I think 95% of the time that's
the 5% right 5% of the time you give
yourself more grace you let yourself off
the hook you take the day off you do
whatever you need especially if you're
struggling with greef
if you're struggling with grief I think
you just have to work your way through
it you have to give yourself a lot of
Grace and a lot of time and and it will
get better and and just please don't go
through it alone but almost everything
else usually the answer is to keep
going because it'll make you more
proud because you're teaching yourself
that you stand up to obstacles then you
overcome reminding yourself every day of
how amazing you are are I think is one
of the greatest gifts you can give
yourself and it's not about ego it's
about confidence confidence comes from a
place of strength ego comes from a place
of weakness and insecurity so it's time
to step into your confidence and remind
yourself of how amazing you really are
this video is going to help so I used to
have a lot of problems with with ego
versus confidence I used to feel like
who am I why do people need to hear my
story uh I was profiling all these
different successful entrepreneurs and
people kept asking well where are you
how come we can't see what you're about
where did you come from and I always
felt like my story doesn't matter I'm
I'm profiling Diva Coggins and Steve
Jobs and and all these people and why do
you care about I mean sure I sold my
first business had a had an exit but
it's nothing compared to what all these
other people have done and I always
shrouded it covered it under ego like
well that's such an egotistical thing to
do but really I was just playing small I
was cheating people the opportunity to
learn to get better to grow from my
story that my story has value it's the
belief that my story had value that took
some time to really work up even making
videos on my channel the number one most
requested person for top 10 was me and I
resisted for maybe two years of even
making an Evan carmichel top 10 cuz I
just felt not good enough I felt like
that's such an ego play and not coming
from a place of confidence and yes my
message has impact has meaning can help
the world and the first Evan carco top
10 came out from my team so my birthday
birthday I think it was my birthday
birthday or Christmas my team put
together with the with the support of my
hardcore fans my first top 10 not videos
you want to watch it I'm a little scared
and that's the one that that went live
on the channel and never since then
we've done a regular series of me being
on the channel but it's it's been a real
progress for me it's been a a real
evolution solution it's taking me a long
time and hopefully you can get there
faster this has been almost 20 years of
me sharing ideas and content and and
slowly stepping into the light and
slowly building more confidence more
belief and I hope that with the content
I'm making and the experiences I'm
sharing you can get there a lot faster
now I've got a three-step process that
I've gone through that can shortcut that
path to confidence for you okay so my
three-step process how do you go from
worrying about being seen as too
egotistical to actually having real
confidence here we go step number one is
play bigger triggers play bigger
triggers are things that you create in
your environment that remind you of who
you want to be of the best version of
you and so I've changed my camera angle
around for this week of filming hope you
guys like it you can see my environment
you can see more of it now and so I've
got play bigger triggers I walk in and I
see Steve Jobs and AP janini my favorite
Entre of all time my parents Howard
Schultz Kanye West even Kanye West is
somebody who I hated at the beginning
cuz he seemed way too egotistical for me
mean but he says some things that that
make sense that make me better he's got
a a picture of himself when he when you
walk into his house he's got this giant
picture of himself which feels very
egotistical but how he explains it like
if you're not your own biggest fan first
nobody else is going to be your fan
right so I love it I've got Kanye on the
wall I have my uh my YouTube plaqu there
I've got a mannequin wearing the believe
hoodie cuz I feel like a superhero
putting this on right the clothes you
wear are play bigger triggers the books
here you know the the the the YouTube
Awards the Doritos bag even
even even this right like I wore I wore
this for for 60 days when I broke my
neck and I was going to throw it away
and my friend Mark drer fan of the
channel said keep it like why would I
keep it it's this nasty duct tape you
know neck mask neck guard I don't know
what it was anyway to keep my neck in
place so it's a reminder and and when I
look at it now when I walk into the
office I feel awesome like I did that
that I I did 60 days in this when I took
it off for 10 minutes every day and I
continued on my tour I didn't go home
and I kept making videos with a
concussion a broken neck and fors at the
front of every seminar that I was
putting on it sometimes feels hard to
remember that I did that just now being
back home and making my content and back
on schedule it's hard to remember that
this I'm this guy I did this and so what
are the play bigger triggers for you
from the clothes you wear from the the
what's on your desktop background and
your cell phone background and the
pictures on the wall and the the things
that you see every day because you might
have one day being being inspired and
motivated maybe after watching this
video you're ready to go awesome but
what do you have on a daily and the
beautiful thing about creating an
environment like this and having play
bigger triggers around you is you only
set it up once you set it up once and
every day I'm I'm working here my
computer's right here every day I got
Steve Jobs star me down and you know AP
janini and my parents and this reminds
me every day of the best of who I am
and so same thing for you what's one
immediate change that you can make to
your environment that's a play bigger
trigger to remind you of the best of who
you are because the goal doesn't be the
next Steve Jobs or the next Kanye West
or next David Goggins it's to take those
pieces to remind you to be the best of
you step number two is act on your
uncomfortable ideas we get great ideas
as entrepreneurs we get great ideas and
especially in moments of boldness and
confidence and courage you get great
ideas it could be when you're in a
shower on an airplane or traveling you
get great ideas for what you want to do
and then tomorrow you tell yourself I I
can't do that that's crazy that that's
too hard that's that's scary that's
uncomfortable teach yourself to act on
your crazy ideas is how you start to
build confidence because if you come up
against a crazy idea and then you allow
yourself to say well that's too scary
that's too hard that's too difficult I
can't do that what you've taught
yourself is you don't have courage
you've taught yourself to come up with
ideas but then not trust in yourself and
so when you come with the next idea
you're telling yourself I don't trust
myself when you set a goal for yourself
to hit hit some Big Goal you don't
believe yourself anymore CU all you've
done is taught yourself that you set
goals you have ideas and you never
follow through you've built this
identity of I'm somebody who doesn't
follow through that's what you need to
start to destroy that's what you need to
destroy and squash out of your life that
identity of I don't follow through your
ideas are genius your ideas are amazing
this is why play bigger TRS will help
you get an idea and your in your awesome
environment act on it do something lean
into the uncomfortable lean into the
things that cause a little bit of your
heart to to beat and cause some anxiety
that's how you start to make the shift
and step number three is then celebrate
your effort celebrate your effort not
the results celebrate the effort that
you tried that you worked your hardest
that you did the uncomfortable thing
whether it worked out or not that you
came up with an idea to email somebody
who could be a potential dream client
for you maybe they didn't write back
maybe they did right back and they told
you you suck and I hate you I never want
to work with you it's the willingness to
go and do the uncomfortable thing the
the fact that you did it that you
tried because that's the only thing
that's separating you from the David
goggin from you from the person that you
want to be if you look at David goin's
story and being 300 lb and overweight
and couldn't do anything it's the will
to get up and do it every day and on a
on a day-by-day basis there's not a lot
of growth if you've never done something
and now it's your first day doing if you
never made a video before and it's your
first day doing it guess what the video
is going to suck you're supposed to suck
at the start that's okay that's normal
but people judge themselves for sucking
at the beginning people judge themselves
for not getting the result right at the
beginning that's the mistake you
celebrate the
effort David gagas with 300 lb
overweight and now is one of the best
ultramarathon runners in the world how
does that happen well it didn't happen
on this first run and if he did his
first run and then said well I suck I'm
not going to keep going then guess what
he never becomes that ultra marathon
runner same thing for you same thing for
me go back and look at my YouTube
channel I'm I'm 6,000 videos in is that
6,000 some crazy number videos in on my
channel go back and watch the first ones
I sucked compared to where I'm at now
and even right now I suck compared to
where I'm going to be in 10 years if I
keep doing this right it's been 11 years
on the channel if I do it for another 11
years I'm going to be even better in 11
years and where I am right now that's
called progress that's normal and so
tying your self-esteem your self-worth
your self-confidence to the willingness
to go off and do it whether you get the
result or not CU if every day you get up
and you start working that hard and
you're insanely proud of your effort you
are going to get the results whoever is
more confident wins when you're hanging
around somebody Whoever has more
confidence is going to be the person who
influences and persuades the other
person and this is for all areas of your
life if you're hanging around people who
are confident that you will not be
successful and you're lacking confidence
in your success get guess what their
confidence in how unsuccessful you're
going to be will breed into you and
you'll feel like you can't do it on the
flip side if you're hanging around
people who believe in you who make you
feel amazing guess what their confidence
in you their belief in you will help you
believe more in yourself this applies to
health and fitness if you're hanging
around people who are always working out
who are eating healthy who are taking
care of their body they're more
confident in their health than you are
in your lack of health and you're going
to become healthier you're going to
start to eat better you're going to
start to work out more just by osmosis
just by you being around them just
through proximity that's it period you
will become that you will become like
the people who you spend the most time
with so when Ed mlet invited me to his
home he's got a beautiful home just
outside of San Diego and he invited me
over I spent the the the evening there
and if I spent more one-on-one time with
Ed I left that night feeling
amazing bold confident ready to take on
my big goals the Big Dreams like let's
go he's got a beautiful environment he's
got a beautiful family uh you know
beautiful
house just motivating as ever and that
that evening I spent with him made me
feel like I could do anything if I spent
more time with Ed then I'm sure I would
be even more successful i' I'd have a
bigger impact I'd be reaching more
people people I'd be making more money
I'd be I'd be way more successful than I
am already right now if I spent more
time with that we talked a lot about
Ed's YouTube and I'm sure if Ed spent
more time with me his YouTube channel
would be blowing up even more than it
already is cuz I'm more confident in
YouTube than he is and he's more
confident in the things that he's great
at than I am and so by us spending more
time together we will both get better at
the things that we're less confident in
when I went to an event in in uh just
outside of Los Angeles I met um Charlie
who runs Cruis mon command another
awesome YouTube channel if you haven't
seen it go check it out and Charlie was
working out every day going for runs
every day whenever we met and had dinner
he was always eating super clean uh
always eating fish and salad with no
dressing like really looking after
himself and for me at that time anytime
that I traveled I kind of used that as
my out as my excuse to say okay it
doesn't matter if I'm as healthy as I am
when I get back I'll get I'll have these
four days away and then I'll be fine
when I come back so i' be eating junk
and pizza and burgers and and everything
else if I spent more time with Charlie I
would be healthier you know and in that
that micro window that we had him just
eating salmon and going for runs every
day made me want to be healthier and if
we had more proximity I'd be even
healthier than I am right now cuz he's
more confident in his health and
routines than I am and so this is really
important because a lot of this is
happening in the background you're not
even noticing it you're not even paying
attention to it if you were around
successful people you would by default
become more successful if you're around
healthier people you'll by default
become healthier it just will happen
without you even thinking about it
you'll be pulled there automatically
because they're more confident in that
area of their life than you are the
problem is most of us have people in Our
Lives who are not happy not successful
not fulfilled not purpose-driven not
healthy they have the potential they're
good people they're just not living the
life that they want to live they don't
have a high degree of confidence that a
life is possible they actually have a
high degree of confidence that things
are not possible and so if you are the
most ambitious person in your circle
that you're around that's a problem
because you're the one giving hope
giving belief giving confidence to other
people people but who's doing it for you
and it's probably not the people
currently in your life or maybe you have
a few special people and that you've got
those people hold on to them real tight
because you really really really need to
have that and so knowing that that's
what happens right knowing that that
this is the way that that your life is
shaped now how can we do it with more
intention so two ideas that I've got for
you and and if you do this if you
actually apply this to your
life things will start to change
dramatically for the better for you for
the money you make for the impact that
you have for the service you can create
for your health for your happiness all
of it step number one is start to really
look at the people in your life the
people who you spend the most time with
the closest proximity how much are they
sucking your energy or giving you energy
how much are they inspiring you how
confident are they in your success and
trying to spend as much time as possible
with the people who are giving you
energy we don't have that many people
who give us energy
you probably don't have that many people
that after you spend time with them
you're feeling more pumped up more bold
more confident more courageous more
willing to go off and and Seize the Day
right when you leave them when you
finish that coffee with them or get off
the phone call or Zoom call with them
you leave them are you ready to seize
the
day or do you feel tired worn out burnt
out stressed out because you took on all
of their problems and you gave them a
great gift and you're trying to
encourage motivate Inspire them but you
don't feel better you might feel better
because you served which is great but
you don't feel more energetic to go off
and Seize the Day on a big scale when
you find those people you have to spend
more time with them you have to find a
way to spend more time you have to you
have to you have to you have to be the
one to reach out to put something on the
calendar to schedule it in so that you
are spending more time with the people
who make you feel better about yourself
and that that may not be uh you know Ed
My Level right I only went to Ed's house
once I haven't been been back to San
Diego since and um when I do go back
hopefully he invites me over again uh so
I'm not calling Ed every week but trying
to find ways to spend more time with the
people who lift you up even if it's
somebody who who is a an acquaintance
somebody who you don't know super well
but every time you're around them you
feel better like try to put a regular
coffee schedule in your calendar with
them even if it feels super awkward even
if you have to say
hey this might sound super weird but
every time we get together every time
I'm around you I leave feeling better
about myself I leave feeling ready to go
and seiz a day and I have more
confidence and boldness and there's just
something about you that makes that come
out in me and I'm super grateful I'm
wondering if you just want to do a if
you're down for a coffee once a month
and we could talk about our business we
could talk about books we're reading our
videos we're watching and just share
that seem may seem like it's coming out
of left field but what do you think
and then see what they say put that on
your list to spend more time with those
people second thing is uh what I call
aspirational mentors
so I believe that you can learn a lot
from people even if you never meet them
that you can have proximity by spending
time with them through their videos
through their books through their
podcasts I've learned a lot through my
own videos through watching Ed my let
top 10 videos I learn a lot I can still
have Ed in my environment even if I had
never known him even if I had never met
him you can still learn a lot from Ed by
watching his YouTube channel by reading
his book by listening to his podcast you
can learn a lot from him you're still
around him is it as good as being in his
house in San Diego getting to one-on-one
coaching no but is it better than just
turning on Netflix and being entertained
absolutely if you watched an ed myet
video every day you are slowly going to
start to think more like Ed melet you
are slowly going to start to see the
world like Ed mlet and apply that for
anybody Tony Robbins uh somebody in
Health and Fitness Nutrition and diet
like whatever it is that you want to get
great at put it as a part of your
calendar schedule that time in I like
videos the best I'm a visual learner so
for me it would be watching the videos
of somebody it's why I have so many
channels cuz I want to consume the
content and then share it with you but
it helps me these are the aspiration
mentor in my life I can learn a lot from
a Steve Jobs even though I will never
meet him because of the video content
that he has produced on interviews that
he's been on you can choose to inject
that into your life so step one are real
life people who you can meet and have
coffee with and learn from and connect
with but step two are aspirational
mentors who you may meet at some point
but may never meet but you can still
learn a lot from them you can still be
inspired by them and if again this is
this happens not in these oneoff big
moments it's daily it's daily you need
to create in your calendar a daily time
to be around the people who inspire you
the most I would look at everybody who
has inspired you at some point make a
list of all of the books you've read or
videos that you watch for me it's it's
videos that I've watched make a list of
them of the people and then put that
into your daily Calendar create a
schedule of 30 videos for the next 30
days that you're going to watch in your
morning routine with intention not while
you're vacuuming guess people don't
vacuum as that's a weird thing you
vacuum as part of your morning routine
not while you're brushing your teeth or
making your B doing something else but
with intention you're going to sit down
and have your coffee or or have your
breakfast and watch the video with
intention to learn from this person
because you want to start to think to
act to adopt the mindset of the ADM
myets of the Oprah Winfrey of the Elon
Musk or Steve Jobs or whoever it is
again that inspires you to be the best
you think about the people who gave you
the most energy and then be around them
even if it's just virtually through
video every single day those two things
it'll dramatically shift your life
forward if you stay with the people who
are in your life right now you will stay
where you are right now if you shift it
to start cutting out or limiting access
to the people who make you feel worse
about yourself and injecting more people
who make you feel better about yourself
and then supplementing that with the
aspirational mentors of the people who
lift you to a higher Stratosphere every
single
day one year from today your life will
be dramatically different but only if
you do it on an every single day basis
make it happen I'm excited to see you
change staying consistent on your
morning routine is the difference
between you having a good life and a
great life the life that you're living
right now which is good listen you have
a good life right now if you're watching
this you have internet you have food you
know you have a place to sleep tonight
you have a you have a pretty good life
you have a pretty good life but it's not
a great life you know you know you're
keepable of more you know you want to do
more you know that where you are right
now is not where you want to be that
imagine a year 2 years 5 years imagine
if you were still in the same spot in 5
years imagine your life your health your
relationships your finances the impact
you're having your your routine your
daily like what you're doing on a
regular and nothing has changed in 5
years
it still be a good life but it's not a
great life right it's not a great life
this is the struggle that you know
you're capable of so much more if you
didn't know you're capable of more
ignorance is bliss you just keep living
your life but when you know you're
capable of more this is the the curse of
the Achievers like you know you're
capable of so much more no matter how
much people look at you and say hey wow
you're doing so well you're doing so
much that that's why you're watching
these videos you are the most ambitious
person that you know people look to you
for guidance and wisdom advice and
support and encouragement and hope and
inspiration like you're the one filling
other people up you're the one inspiring
other people to do better to be more to
go after their dreams that's you but
who's doing that for
you you know you're capable of so much
more and so how do you get it how do you
how do you do the work well it's a daily
thing this is this is part of the
challenge is it's a daily thing it gets
boring
boring it gets boring to do the exact
same thing every day to stay consistent
on what you said you were going to do
and we start to doubt ourselves you have
days where you're motivated inspired
ready to Take On The World feeling
amazing and other days where you don't
feel so good and you think wake up
feeling like who am I I I can't do this
what I said I was going to do that you
look at your goals like I'm I'm going to
do that there's no way I'm going to do
that me I'm going to stay in bed
it's the thing Achievers don't talk
about is there's a lot of days when you
just don't feel like you're worthy of it
you don't believe in yourself you don't
think that you can do
it and it's just that consistency that
prevents you from doing the thing
because you have the days when you're on
fire and then entire days maybe weeks
sometimes where you're just not doing
anything and so how do you how do you
keep that momentum how do you keep that
consistency it starts with a morning
routine and the goal of morning routine
is to help you
feel motivated bold courageous ready to
take on the day that's what the goal of
a morning routine is everybody's got a
morning routine if you're watching this
you got a morning routine everybody
doesn't have a morning routine most
people actually wake up like an accident
right most people wake up and they fall
into their day and they look at their
phone and it's other people's
emergencies and other people's demands
for your time that's most people's day
but for you if you're watching this
you're you're an achiever
and you have some kind of morning
routine but most people's morning
routine are also broken because you're
not doing it consistently enough or
you're not doing it with enough intent
so if you ask what's the goal of a
morning routine the goal of a morning
routines to get you bold and prepped and
ready for the day let me ask you this if
you were to for the next year of your
life right 365 days the next year of
your life you're going to wake up and do
something that would make you feel bold
powerful courageous motivated not asking
you to wake up feeling bold powerful
courageous motivated but to wake up
tired however you wake
up I woke up tired today you wake
up and then you do something that will
help you feel bold powerful motivated
courageous and ready to take on the day
if you woke up and did that for the next
365 how much does your life change how
much does the next year change how much
does the does the Imp impact that you're
making does the actual momentum that
you're taking towards your goals how
much does that change if in the next
year you actually did
that it should be tremendously it should
be dramatically because no matter how
much you do in your morning routine one
you're probably not super consistent on
it and two you're not getting the
feeling even if you are that's what
needs to change you are always in
control of how you feel you're always in
control you you may not be in control of
the world and the results that are
happening and how people are acting
around you but you are always in control
you can be you can choose to be in
control of how you feel there's the
great quote that there's nothing either
good nor bad but thinking makes it so
when something happens you have a choice
right your subconscious mind can take
over and I'll I'm going to give you a
super important hack in this video on
how to do it but you have a choice you
can anytime choose to see that thing
that happened as a negative or positive
the problem is we let our our
subconscious mind take over we let our
stories and our patterns take over and
we let that take us into the negative
and when you're in the negative you're
not productive you're not happy you're
not fulfilled you're not in action mode
you're not building momentum and you
don't hit your goals how do you override
the subconscious mind how do you get
into that positive place when you are in
a negative place this is really
important cuz when you're watching maybe
a video like this or when you're
inspired you don't need it as much right
when you're inspired and you're ready to
go you're you're on fire you're taking
action nothing can stop you you've had
these moments where you felt super
fulfilled whether it was meeting
somebody or watching video or listening
to a a podcast or reading a book you had
these moments that you felt amazing and
then what did you do you went to work
and when something bad happened you just
overcame and kept going but it's when
you're in the in the depths when you're
not feeling great when something really
bad happens to you what do you
do here's the hack that I use that if
you can apply this Con consistently it
will change your life it will change
your life it's catching those those down
moments and saying three words three
simple words it's the best it's the best
anytime you find yourself complaining
it's the best anytime you find yourself
in a negative situation it's the best
anytime you find yourself stressed
overwhelmed out of control it's the best
it's the best it's the best tell
yourself it's the
best and we're trying to rewire our
subconscious mind and you won't catch it
all the time and don't judge yourself
for catching it all the time but if you
can catch it once and you can catch it
again the next day and you can catch it
three times the next day you're going to
start to train yourself you're going to
start to catch it more often you're
going to start catching it instead of 1%
of the time 4% of the time to 20% of the
time to 50% of the time you'll catch it
more because you're building the muscle
of catching it it's the best why why is
it the best well again there's nothing
neither good nor bad but thinking makes
itself you can choose to see the best in
any situation I've used this for small
things and big things so even today so
today in the morning I decided to do a
whole bunch of
squats my legs were burning me uh right
after that I take the dogs out for their
morning walk and what I've been doing in
the morning is after I take the dogs for
a walk I climb up 13 flights of stairs
holding both my dogs I got these two
little dogs they're they're maybe 12 lb
each and I hold one under each arm and I
walk up the
stairs my legs were jell at the start
and I remember getting to uh the sixth
floor like oh my gosh I don't know if I
can do this my legs are jell these dogs
are heavy just feel like 1,000 lb I just
want to quit I just want to get on the
elevator and go all the way up to the
13th floor I uh the this the voice in my
head tells me well but I already did all
the squats we find our way out right we
we give oursel logical reasons logical
outs from situations I did all these
squats so that kind of counts right I
mean I don't normally do squats in the
morning I did them here that that should
count as as half the the clim of stairs
right like no no no no this is this is
the practice this is the best this right
now is the best this is my chance to
show myself what I'm made of that those
extra seven flights of stairs do not own
me and even if I'm walking at half pace
I'm going to get to the 13th floor this
is this is the debate inside my own head
as I'm climbing the stairs and this
seems trivial right this is this is not
a big deal this is oneoff what happens
doesn't really matter
but in those moments when you want to
quit when you want to give yourself the
out when you want to to play small when
you're giving yourself that excuse for
not doing it how you react becom super
super important this is another small
little battle that I won by going all
the way up to the 13th floor and then
hitting 13 and open in the door that
feeling of of pride of belief in myself
cuz I overcame the difficult thing you
want to build self-confidence you have
to do difficult things every time you go
up against something that is difficult
that is hard that is scary and you're
battling yourself and then you get
through it and you do it whether you get
a great result or not that wasn't my
best climb up but that I con that I
continued and that I finished it that I
got
there that makes you feel great about
yourself that's how you build the
selfconfidence self- Lov self- resect by
doing the difficult things by having
that inner debate with yourself and then
choosing the path of the path of growth
choosing that path of growth instead of
choosing a smaller path and letting
yourself off the hook cuz other people
might look at you and say what a great
job you're doing how hard you're pushing
yourself and maybe you're pushing
yourself too hard but they just have
lower standards than you this is the
battle with yourself to be proud of
yourself it's the best so this is my
this is my fastest hack my fastest way
to get into growth Evan proud Evan
believe Evan that when I find myself
complaining about something negative in
my life I say this is the best this is
the best this is my chance to show
myself and the world who Evan Carmichael
is and what does that do well one it's a
it's a little mental trick cuz even just
doing that even if you just say that say
you can practice it right now say out
loud this is the best think about some
negative situation this is the best this
is my chance to show myself and the
world what I'm made of tell yourself
that instantly you're going to find
maybe you're not all the way amped up
ready to go but you're feeling a little
bit better than you were before and all
you need is that little T that little
tiny bit of
inspiration to force you into action
mode the point of saying it's the best
isn't just some motivational pump up
it's to get you the courage to then take
the action and do the thing because all
you need are those few seconds of
courage to take the action to then make
yourself proud the goal of it's the best
is to get you into action mode now what
about bigger things what about what
about bigger problems well listen when I
broke my neck last year on my tour right
if you guys don't know the story I broke
my neck in two spots and had a
concussion and compressed my spine and
had all these issues what did I do
I told myself this is the best it's the
same strategy guys it's the best this is
my chance to show myself in the world
what I'm made of And when everybody told
me to go home on my tour and just to lie
in bed and relax I finished my tour I
only missed one spot on my tour because
I was in a hospital in Colorado every
other stop we hit and I sat at the front
with ice packs for 4 hours answering
questions and doing my event was it the
best event uh no was I on top of my game
as much is before no uh but I finished
it and it was an inspiration to a lot of
the people who came out too they say I'm
I'm complaining about the guy who cut me
off in traffic on the way here and
you're sitting here with a broken neck
at the front doing the workshop like yep
right let's go it's the best and
ultimately if you step above it if you
believe like I believe that your purpose
comes from your
pain whatever happened to you your that
that deepest darkest moment in your life
life that you never want to experience
again that you never want to go back to
again that that pain that's your purpose
helping other people never experience
that pain helping other people go
through that pain and feel like they're
not alone like you were alone that's
your calling that's your purpose for the
rest of your life that will fill you up
for the rest of your life for me helping
entrepreneurs not struggle as much as I
struggled at the beginning will fill me
up forever
forever your purpose comes from your
pain and so the greatest pain of all
time that you ever went through is the
best it's the best you could choose to
be overwhelmed by it that pain that
happened to you will Define you one way
or the other either you continue to live
in that pain or try to forget that pain
and never live a fulfilled life or you
choose to serve and you choose to help
and you choose to understand that there
are millions of people right now who are
struggling with that same thing and
they're suffering alone and they could
use your
help it's the best so whether
it's getting cut off in traffic whether
it's breaking your neck on a tour uh
whether it's some crazy thing that
happened to you when you were younger
some painful
moment it's the best it's the best and
you try to catch it and use that as your
3 seconds of courage to then take the
action that would make you proud because
if you did that consistently you start
to catch it more often you start to take
those complaining moments that you have
even if it's just complaining inside
your head maybe you're not complaining
out loud but you're complaining inside
your head you're about to give yourself
a break you're about to tell yourself to
go easy and have an excuse for not doing
something and then you wake up tomorrow
you're not proud of yourself
anymore try to catch it today tomorrow
this week catch it catch it just once
catch it and say no not this time this
is the best this is my chance to show
myself in the world what I am made of
good luck the fact that you look at your
calendar today tomorrow next week and
nothing excites you okay great what can
you shift and it may require a wholesale
change it may require you doing some
drastic thing but more likely you could
probably just do one small shift like
just start building momentum just start
doing one little thing every day to
start to train yourself to start to just
push the ball a little bit forward
because often we think we have to make
some giant change and the only answer is
to move to Mexico and then it never
happens because to move to Mexico takes
you however many you know months and
budget and all this stuff you get stuck
in planning mod instead of
doing what's a small step what's a small
tweak that you can make to today's
calendar to inject more energy into it
with something that you're going to love
doing that will give you more energy
that then now you have energy for other
things as well right some kind of
immediate
momentum because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special special celebration if you
put a hash believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for 10 more amazing rules from
Tom billu check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there don't buy into the myth that
you're too old because that is going to
slow you down there is a quote that
haunts me to my core which is genius is
a young man man's game why is genius a
young man's game part of it is
definitely energy part of it is the
naive of the beginner